recycling is literally a scam you know  this recycling symbol that you see on  everything that is plastic well that's  not actually the recycling symbol this  is the actual recycling symbol created  in 1970 while this symbol with that  little number inside was created by the  Plastics industry in 1988 and the reason  why they look so similar is because they  intentionally wanted to confuse you see  the Plastics industry wanted to make you  believe that the plastic you buy is  recyclable when in reality most of it  isn't less than 10 of all of it is  actually ever recycled subscribe to  learn more about how the world really  works